[Música]
Hola Bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de France 24 sobre el Éxodo los
saluda Julieth riaño
[Música]
el freno de Estados Unidos al ingreso
irregular de venezolanos por la frontera
Sur dejó a cientos de migrantes varados
algunos quedaron bloqueados en México en
el que sería el último tramo de su viaje
y a otros los dejó en pausa en países
como Panamá en el inicio de su tránsito
por Centroamérica allí algunos tratan de
ganar dinero para comprar un boleto de
regreso a Venezuela pero otros dependen
de la solidaridad pese a las
restricciones la movilidad continúa y en
Solo dos semanas al menos 15 mil
venezolanos entraron y salieron de un
albergue improvisado con capacidad
reducida nuestro corresponsal Óscar
zulbarán con la historia
cerca de las antiguas instalaciones de
una fábrica que operaba en Ciudad de
Panamá y que hoy funciona como un
albergue para migrantes venezolanos
Andrés ha improvisado esta barbería
trata de reunir 240 dólares para pagar
el boleto aéreo que le permita volver a
su país tras su intento fallido de
Ingresar a Estados Unidos no este que
nosotros sacamos gran mayoría de dinero
pero por lo menos se hace algo para
también colaborar con los muchachos acá
con los cortes solidarios y cualquier
cosa cualquier ayuda uno se empareja
pues las autoridades panameñas piden
ayuda para manejar la llegada y salida
de cientos de venezolanos que arriban a
diario El País hasta ahora solo pueden
facilitar logística seguridad y salud en
el único refugio en la capital un galpón
alquilado por el gobierno venezolano los
países no nos encontramos recibiendo
apoyo luego el apoyo necesario de parte
de los organismos internacionales en
cuanto a la asignación de recursos estas
personas quieren retornar
voluntariamente es lo que le pide en el
estado panameño es lo que piden en toda
la región centroamericana
Javier y Charlotte miembros de la
comunidad lgbti tienen un mes en las
calles aquí duermen la diferencia de
Andrés ellos no tienen como reunir el
dinero para regresar a Venezuela
nadie es muy duro mi mamá se desespera
llora todos los días así todos los días
yo hablo con ella y le digo que yo no
aguanto más y esa que me da fuerza es la
que me ayuda la que me dice que siga
adelante que yo he sido fuerte que que
no me derrumben unos pocos metros Julio
un joven de apenas 18 años después es un
paso por la selva no cree que su
situación actual sea difícil y cuando
estaba en la selva así decía que mi amor
Y eso pero no no me arrepentía del medio
de otra forma
intoxicado ya no podía caminar No podía
comer me metía con la boquilla la
vomitaba estaba grave los venezolanos
parados en Panamá son un nuevo episodio
de la crisis migratoria de la que ha
sido parte del istmo sus autoridades
junto a Costa Rica y Colombia esperan
reunirse con los organismos
internacionales encargados en busca de
apoyo para la repatriación voluntaria
el cambio en la política migratoria de
Estados Unidos hacia los venezolanos
sorprendió a muchos en el camino Richard
paredes de 19 años fue uno de ellos tras
recorrer siete países fue deportado dos
días antes de que entrara en vigencia el
acuerdo entre Estados Unidos y México
Richard logró regresar a Venezuela en un
vuelo humanitario él nos cuenta su
historia en el siguiente relato en
primera persona
decidirme también porque allá hay otro
estilo de vida pues allá podría llevar
mi familia Podría tener muchas cosas más
que aquí no lo voy a tener que salir el
día 12 de septiembre Duré casi un mes y
medio para poder llegar a México
lo más difícil fuera hacerlo
duramos siete días y medio caminando
sí duramos dos días y medio caminando
cinco meses porque Se nos acabó la
comida y se veía muchísima gente
cruzando por esa selva también mucha
gente que se quedó ahí durmiendo en esa
frontera también en carpa con niños la
mayoría todo eran venezolanos hay mucha
gente también que se cae en países
Trabajando para poder reunir pasaje para
poder seguir salir de Panamá a Costa
Rica y llegué tarde noche salimos un
autobús así no me quedaba mucho Pues en
México Duré casi un mes también ya
nosotros nuevamente entregó el día a día
de inmigración y ya estábamos preso
nosotros no sabíamos nada duramos cuatro
días presos y cuando nos sueltan No
bajan por el puente de México y no dicen
que no han ahí no van a una visa un
papel para poder entrar de forma legal
Cuando llegamos abajo tenemos un papel
de deportación también de México tenemos
que salir en 15 días y fue cuando nos
enteramos que habían puesto el título 42
y nada y todo el mundo empezó a llorar
todo el mundo se quedó como que está
pasando güey
[Música]
yo gasté en todo el trayecto para llegar
a Estados Unidos como 1800 dólares
hay mucha plata prestada También
muchas familiares que me ayudaron ya con
todo ese viaje yo quedé endeudado es por
eso decidí regresarme trabajar y pagando
poco a poco
no aquí la situación en Venezuela es
difícil
por la economía que por lo menos ahorita
un sueldo aquí no te alcanza o sea te
alcanza como para comprar comida Cuando
regresé llega a mí mismo trabajo que era
el taller donde yo trabajo trabajamos a
domicilio también
se fueron así pues es muy rudo invasión
con niños yo no volvería a emigrar
porque se pasa mucho trabajo pero la
única manera Es que yo emigrete yo pueda
sacar mi pasaporte todo legal y pueda
viajar un avión un país directo sin
tanto problema el pasado 12 de octubre
entró en vigor el nuevo plan del
gobierno byden para gestionar el flujo
de venezolanos hacia su país con este se
permitirá el ingreso de sólo 24.000 de
ellos una iniciativa limitada y que no
responde a la cantidad mucho mayor de
venezolanos que llegan a las fronteras
de Estados Unidos hasta que inmigrantes
de Francia 24 los invitamos a comentar
en nuestras redes sociales con el
hashtag migrantes f-24 sigan con más
información en francés 24 y France
24.com
[Música]